We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two David p.
Here's a very funny, a voicemail of related
to the alt-right.
Take a listen to this.
Hello, this is Richard.
Um, I wanted to know, do you think that the
old right has any anything going for them?
Like I think they're right about anything
because it does seem to me that, you know,
there's differences between racism.
Why?
Well, why, why shouldn't we listen to them,
respond to them?
Thanks.
So listen, this is something that comes up
sometimes and this is, uh, one of these areas
where if I want to, I could say, you know
what, I may disagree with the outright on
most things, but we agree that oxygen is necessary
for human life.
So they're not all bad.
What is often missing from these conversations
of, but David, can't you find x or y that
you agree with, with such a political group?
And if you agree on those things, maybe they're
not all bad.
The point is, what defines a political movement
is what makes it different from others.
So coming up with a list of areas with which
I, a in which I am in agreement with the outright
on relatively insignificant noncontroversial
things doesn't really tell us anything about
the value of the outright as a movement.
But when it comes to what defines the outright,
what the alt-right represents culturally and
socially, and to, to the degree that they
have economic policy economically, it's bad.
Period.
That's it.
So like, yeah, I mean I can come up with things
where I would probably agree with almost anyone
who is not severely disturbed mentally and
disconnected from the real world, but that's
not really a value when we're trying to figure
out what political movements, what cultural
movements, what societal movements are going
to push us in a positive direction rather
than a negative one.
So I don't know, there's probably something
that the outright gets right kind of by default.
Most humans get something right by default.
The broken clocks are right twice a day.
But with regard to the defining characteristics
of the outright and the movement and the vision
that they have of what they want to change,
the things they want to change that distinguish
them.
Everybody can say, well, we're against corruption.
Okay?
Most people would at least say that it's not
really controversial.
The unique defining characteristics are basically
all bad.
Oh, we've got a great bonus show for you today.
Donald Trump says he is going to look to cut
the defense budget in the future.
Now the problem is he may not even understand
the reality of when we talk about the defense
budget.
There's rarely ever serious discussions about
cutting it.
There are discussions about slowing down the
rate at which the defense budget is growing
and I don't even think Trump understands that,
but we'll talk about that on the bonus show.
We will talk about the newly released Ronald
Reagan tapes where he refers to those monkeys
from African countries, uh, meant to get to
this on yesterday's bonus show and didn't.
We will also talk about a 10 year old boy
who is charged with assault for injuring a
classmate in a dodge ball like game.
Um, those stories and many more, including
the latest updates with the youtube, CNN,
twitch, uh, fiasco that we've been embroiled
in.
All on the bonus show, two ways to get access
to the bonus show, become a member at ww
w.
Dot.
Joined pacman.com become a patron@patrion.com
slash David Patton show.
Look forward to speaking to you then the David
Pakman show@davidpacman.com
[inaudible].